The Joe Rogan Experience people have a
hard time you know keeping it together
yeah and when something like marijuana
comes along but that doesn't mean that
it should be illegal that means there
should be some real counseling and there
should be places that people can go
where they can talk to someone and
therapy and there's there should be a
way to make it legal I 100 agree I mean
one thing we know is that the War on
Drugs hasn't worked the billions of
dollars that the United States has spent
on the War on Drugs has actually had the
reverse effect and as you know well the
biggest drug epidemic in America's
history was created right here in
America by the pharmaceutical companies
yes well that's how I found out about
you from the Oxycontin Express that that
was so eye-opening and when you did that
what channel will you guys on back then
current TV was Al Gore's television
channel it was Al Gore's that's
hilarious
it was it was actually a really
interesting experiment so it was right
before YouTube started and basically
they were trying to the idea was
democratizing television it was giving
young kids out there a platform to go
out there and explore the world and come
back with these stories so that's how I
started what year was this this was
2005 or six oh wow 2005 when was when I
started yeah
um a long time ago and then YouTube came
around it turns out that YouTube was a
bigger success but I really the show
that I worked on was called Vanguard and
it was all these young journalists who
most of us had just graduated but they
basically gave us cameras and in my case
get my husband at the time with my
boyfriend we both applied they hired us
both and then we traveled all around the
world he would film I would be on camera
and then we'd come back I'd edit he'd
write we'd do these stories together and
one of the stories we did was the
prescription bill story The Oxycontin
Express which is how we met because yeah
tweeted about it well I think your work
really changed the way people were aware
of that problem in Florida and they it
changed the laws because they didn't
have databases back then which was 100
on on purpose yeah so you could go from
yeah you could go Doctor shopping you
could go from pill Mill to pill Mill or
pain clinic to pain clinic to buy
prescription pills the amazing thing is
my husband is still reporting on this
his actually had a film on CNN that's
coming on HBO Max uh in April and it's
called American pain so I don't know do
you remember the the twins that were
running American pain it was the biggest
uh pill Mill or
prescription pain clinic in in South
Florida it's called American vein and it
was run run by these two twins who were
born they were born conjoined twins at
Birth and then they ran a steroid
business and they got in trouble and
then they realized that actually they
could make a lot more money from selling
Oxycontin they could from selling
steroids so they opened this little
small strip mall pain clinic
and as you saw you know people started
coming in from all over the country and
buying and the doctors wouldn't even
look at them and they were prescribing
pills like it was Tic Tacs and this we
we found out about them because we were
reporting in Kentucky and we were the
sheriff who was you know overdoses all
around them people you know dying
devastating his community and a lot of
the pill bottles had this name American
pain
and we started we went down there and we
took out the camera and my husband took
out the camera and we the first shot we
got immediately within minutes this big
SUV came with two big guys who were
threatening us and started yelling us
and telling us to leave that we weren't
allowed to film
so we drove off and I'm driving and this
is actually in the film but I'm driving
and my husband's filming and they're
right behind us and we we decided to
film this as the last thing we were
heading to the airport and we're driving
down 985 to head to the airport and they
start following us and then I realize I
have very little gas so I stopped at the
gas station and they stop right behind
us and they come out of the car and
these were big guys and the day before
we'd been watching The Sopranos so in my
mind they were coming out guns of
Blazing and they were going to kill us
both so I drove off I was so nervous and
I drove off and they continued following
us and I didn't put gas in the car so
we're on 9.95 and we called 9-1-1 and
said hey we're being followed by this
car and explain the situation and then I
ran out of gas as we were filming and I
pulled over to the curb but they were so
sort of surprise shot they had no idea
confused about what was happening that
they just parked behind us and came out
of and they never came out of the car
and then the police arrived and then
they made up an excuse that they thought
I wasn't an old girlfriend or something
like that but we my husband took down
their license plates and found out their
names and it was the George Brothers
Jeff and Chris George who were running
the biggest prescription or pill Mill in
America's history they were making I
think something like 40 million dollars
a year out of this small little pill
Mill paint you know strip mall clinic
and uh and it was incredible and then
and then a year later they were they're
now do they one of them just left prison
and the other one was still in prison so
those were the guys that were following
you the guys that owned the organization
that owned American pain the
organization was just a strip mall
Clinic pain clinic with thousands of
patients that would come in and out and
you know tons of doctors writing
prescription pills and when we were
working at the time where we'd been
interviewing off the Record a D.A agent
who didn't want to go on the record that
we later found out was actually
investigating them and they had wiretaps
so in Darren's movie uh is he got his
hands on all the wiretaps so you could
hear them and part of it there's a part
where they talk about us and our film
and how we were trying to look into them
so it all sort of came yeah that's it
South Florida yeah so South Florida pain
clinic and then they changed to a new
location a bigger location and called it
uh yeah that's it called it American
pain such as what a great name by the
way yeah and those are the two brothers
down there with the fish yep that's the
two brothers those are the guys that
were chasing you yeah wow well they
found a loop it's a crazy story so
they're in prison and Darren he sends
them an email and says hey guys remember
that guy they chased on 995.
I'm doing a film about you do you want
to be interviewed and they did it's a
great film what did they say did they
just spill the beans about what they did
and they talked a lot about sort of how
they grew up and why they did it
um
it's yeah I think it's interesting when
they'd already gotten in trouble so they
had really nothing to lose at that point
but what wasn't what they were doing
legal no it was uh what they were so
that is the difficulty and that's why
actually so little people so there
should have been a lot more people that
went to prison Unfortunately they didn't
so the government Gets You Through other
things racketeering charges
bribery male fraud it's always these
other that's the you know the biggest I
think outrage about the whole opiate
crisis is that there have been almost
not no pharmaceutical executive that has
been gone to prison the pharmaceutical
companies are the ones that were
actually making the big money right and
it's not just the sacklers of Purdue
it's also the generic companies that
were making even more
and uh and no one went nobody was
actually I mean nothing practically
happened to them no one did time in
prison and it's so sad when you find out
how many people lost their lives and how
many people even if they're alive their
lives are destroyed I mean Joe having
traveled and ex reported on this
um the opiate crisis for so long it's
whole communities that have been
devastated it's it's horrible it's the
biggest sort of outrageous
um thing that has happened in America
and uh and it was made here again we can
blame others but it was made here and
because we allowed it to happen it's
just amazing the deception that was
involved too they they tried to claim
that they weren't addictive and
and they were just passing them out to
people and it's I mean I um I had I
talked before about this I had my nose
fixed I had a deviated septum and uh
when I got out of the operating room
um I was uh kind of shocked that it
wasn't painful I was like this is fine
this is just a little mildly
uncomfortable and the doctor tried to
give me two different prescriptions for
opiates
and I was like I'm not going to use
those
um because I I had had knee surgery and
I I also didn't take pain pills I don't
mind paying what I really don't like is
feeling stupid and when I took um I
think it was I don't remember it was
Percocets or Vicodin I don't remember
but one of my first knee surgeries they
gave me one of those and I took it and I
remember being on my couch when I lived
in New York and uh just sitting there
watching TV like this
feeling so stupid and thinking oh my God
I'm never taking this [__] again like
whatever this is doing to me first of
all I don't think it really stopped the
pain because I remember getting up
because I had to go to the bathroom and
I was it was like Liquid Fire was going
through my knee and I was like if it
still [__] hurts like this and I'm
dumb as [__] like I am not taking these
anymore I know the ease with which they
were dispensed and are still being
dispensed to some degree my doctor was
trying to force me to take them he was
like he was like just you really should
take these like you're going to be in
pain I go well it's just a little pain
like is it worse than this right now he
goes it could be I'm like how could it
get worse why is it going to get worse
yeah like if it doesn't if it just is
mildly uncomfortable now and like so the
doctor was just like you should take
this and I was like why would I take
that but I don't I wasn't I didn't
understand why
like I like couldn't I come back to you
if I'm in pain like if I'm not in pain
now why do you want it was this weird
conversation where it's like I don't
know if he was incentivized to try to
try to prescribe them if he felt like it
would be good for him I did I didn't
understand it like couldn't you just if
you wrote the prescriptions and I didn't
take it like what do you care but he
wanted me to take him yeah it was weird
so strange I mean that's what was
happening with Oxycontin that's what was
happening later on we did another story
on fentanyl that was what was happening
with fentanyl too you had a company and
we investigated one particular company
and I think it's the only CEO of a
company that he's now in in prison
actually for what he was doing but yeah
he was bribing essentially and he was
charged with bribing he was bribing
doctors and there was a quota and he was
basically telling them if you prescribe
more of our product which was fentanyl I
have a spray fentanyl called substance
if you prescribe more we will give you
more money
they were he was paying them out and
take taking them on trips luxurious
trips around the world and telling them
not only to prescribe this medication to
people who have headaches and back pain
and the medication that is made and FDA
approved only for breakthrough cancer
patients but yet you go to the doctor
and you say you have a headache and this
guy knows that he can get a kickback
from the company and so oh you should
take this this drug how much of a Kid
Rock was it
uh it was significant it was in the
thousands of dollars some doctors got
hundreds of thousands of dollars and so
they were incentivized yeah there was a
big incentive to do it yeah and they
were also invited to these luxury
vacations and to go speaking fees what
they said is that they were paying them
for speaking fees which basically was
the code bribes yeah I have a good
friend who used to be a pharmaceutical
representative and he explained to me
how it works that he would not just know
the doctor but he got to know he knew
who the doctor's kids names were he
would show up at their baseball games
and he would give them gifts he would
take them out to dinners and it was all
about cultivating these relationships
and that it was all about like I'm your
friend and you know like and they wanted
to have this sort of weird cronyism
weird sort of relationship where even if
it wasn't illegal like clearly he was
influencing them to sell more pills
so crazy yeah
yeah it's uh it's it's crazy and it's
crazy that it's still happening and I'm
it's just shocking that not more people
have gotten in trouble because what has
changed in Florida because they they did
change and they made a database right
there's a database right now which was
the biggest thing that didn't so babe
you could go to 10 doctors in one day
and get 150 pills from each doctor at
the end of the day you'd have 1500 bills
that no one would know about it and then
you'd grab those pills and go and sell
them to other places of the country
where you could get 20 20 times more for
the same drug
um yeah so the databases and it's just
much harder I think there's one of the
things that I remember that we reported
on it that you shouldn't be able to
prescribe and dispense at the same
location because it's a conflict of
interest right if you have if you're
going to make money out of the sailing
selling of those pills you shouldn't it
shouldn't be at the same place where
you're prescribing them because then
there's an incentive for you to
prescribe because you're making money
from the sale of those bills
um so that was happening in Florida as
well and it's not allowed in a lot of
other states and then the horrible truth
is that a lot of those people became
addicted and then they had to get it on
the black market so then they were
getting fentanyl laced heroin yeah and
massive amount of overdoses yeah the
progression was Oxycontin and then it
was Fenton and then it was heroin and
then it became Fentanyl